let's just kind of jump right in here
give give our readers an overview of
what second chance is is about and kind
of what drew you to this project
a second chance is a story about
richard davis who
um is a very brave man and a very
unusual man he
invented the modern day bulletproof vest
concealable body armor and to prove that
it worked he shot himself point blank
over
190 times
and um
when he invented this he was a
out-of-work pizzeria owner so it's
really kind of a rags-to-riches story
for him
um
but it's about a lot more than that it's
about um
the lives we tell ourselves to move
forward the the
mythology that people want to believe as
a society or as a group
it's about friendship it's about
deception this it's a kind of a long
decades-long story about this
inventor salesman
uh founder of a huge company and a lot
of the people that were involved in his
life over these decades
so so early in the film kind of
piggybacking off of what you're saying
early in the film you describe his story
with the words as a metaphor for for you
know um our country and you use the
words absurd and frightening this is
about 10 minutes into the movie as this
becomes more and more true for where
we're at as a society
what do you hope
kind of reader uh people realize viewers
realize about where we're at and where
we're headed well that's for everyone to
take away on their own i mean um
there's a moment in the film there's a
character
in a way opposing um
richard is his character aaron
aaron westrick he's a police officer who
was shot and saved by richard's vest so
in a way richard saved this man as he
richard saved over a thousand lives with
his invention
and um
aaron at some point becomes a
whistleblower in a very important case
uh surrounding second chance the company
and
there's some
in terms of deception there's some
things about richard's past including
his origins and the mythology around him
that
fall into question there's an unreliable
storytelling and narrator here and
what i found amazing in that moment was
that aaron westrick said he
prefers to believe in the myth and the
legend
and
that there's something so true in that
for
us as a society um
in a way reminded me of the great film
by john ford the man who shot liberty
valence
um where they say print the legend and
people want to believe that and
you know it's not easy to believe in
what is true and these days it's not
even clear what is true we don't know
and the film
delves into some of those questions
right and it does a really really great
job of kind of exploring those questions
without necessarily wanting to answer
them because everybody kind of has their
different ideas of what happened and you
know some people are more suspicious of
of richard than others um
and and
regarding the product the second chance
is product itself the the bulletproof
vest it's one of those things that we're
all pretty aware of but we don't really
know the full story behind
how it was made and so as you got deeper
into this project was there anything
that you found shocking about this
backstory like that you found
particularly shocking the most amazing
thing is that he invented it out of
nothing i mean he had no money he hit he
was a former pizzeria owner and he
actually sewed materials together by
hand in his basement and started testing
it by shooting at it in his basement of
a townhouse which frightened his
neighbors you know
so the fact that really which is
something very american right that these
creating things out of nothing and
launching a multi-million dollar
business out of your basement
this is so truly american that
that part of it um
[Music]
that was really astounding and and
really again as i said his bravery that
that to prove that it worked he was
prepared to shoot himself point blank
in the chat in you know and thank god he
filmed it you know
we had access to all these great
archives you know he's also a movie
maker he made eight hours of film
right yeah yeah recreations of cops and
and cops shooting at bad guys bad guy
shooting cops you know
comedy film
you know propaganda films to
get people more frightened by you know
bad guys with guns so they were buying
product and increasing this escalation
of
weapons and armor so
it was all
everywhere we turned there was another
layer to the story
right so so and
as you were because with the
documentaries um a lot of
the the finished product is shaped in
the editing room
and so what kinds like how did how did
editing this film shape the way that you
told the story and how did it i mean did
it change any of the elements that we
see on the screen or was did you have a
pretty
um solid idea of how you wanted to go
about this right off the bat
no i i i didn't know and and when you go
to start shooting
um even a fiction film but even more in
documentary when we went to start
filming richard he was not what we
expected
um so everything starts to change and
evolve as you're shooting
the editing process took quite some time
i worked with a great editor aaron
wickenden who cuts a lot from
morganelleville
and
it took a while to shape the film to
find it um
how do you play with the unreliable
narrator when do you reveal
elements of the story that are suddenly
twisted on their head and it's not what
you thought it took time to find that
shape and um
and also i i i want to say i like
richard davis um i don't agree with a
lot of his philosophies i i disagree
with them
he's made some very serious mistakes
that cost
people and
in some cases it cost someone their life
um
but he was also very brave he was
charming he was generous with us he was
generous with a lot of people
and even the people he hurt even in the
you see in the film they still talk
about him in some loving way and i was
interested in that contradiction
of of of his character and the reaction
he elicited out of people
um
so finding that balance in the editing
room took some time aaron was great at
that and um at a certain point i showed
it to a lot of people a lot of different
filmmaker friends were in a hearthstone
and
joshua oppenheimer and joshua
spent three four hours on a zoom call
with me talking about an early cut
and that was very instrumental in
finding the shape of the film and then
he saw it again we talked again and he
came on board as an ep and that was
really helpful um in terms of shaping
the film
so so you said that at the beginning of
this of this answer you said that
um richard was not what you expected can
you kind of clue me into what you did
expect like what were you when you got
to him were you apprehensive or
when the producers pitched the idea to
me they pitched it as a fiction film
they said they were going to make the
doc and they want to know if i would
make a fictional story out of it i think
it would actually be a great fictional
film and i hope someone makes it but the
more i heard them talk and the more i
saw the footage i wanted to make the dot
and the footage they provided me and the
documents and what they told me
it really sounded like it was going to
be a rags to riches rise and fall story
and that richard was going to be this
very um charming person who was going to
go deep into
the mistake
that he had made um
let's say with the xylon vest
specifically which comes in the second
half of the film
but
the more we dug into the film the more
we realized there were other mistakes
and then when i started to talk to him
i realized he wasn't that
willing or able to go to
the depth of
facing some of the things from his past
um
going back to what we said earlier he
also wants to believe some sort of a
legend or a myth or a deception
um
so i didn't have full access i feel to
the inside of him or maybe he doesn't
have full access to that or doesn't want
to go there
which i understand not everyone wants to
do that it's not an easy thing to do
so at that point in the shooting of the
film it opened up to
the other characters you know
i started to realize to understand
richard in the story we need to
understand the people around him
in a way citizen kane we understand cain
through people around him
so his second wife kathleen became so
important to the story her profound way
of seeing things and speaking or
aaron westrick and his wife kim who was
such an eloquent speaker or
tim poczenski the teenage teenager who's
now an adult that had a very
bizarre and deadly encounter almost with
with richard davis so these characters
started to inform the story more than i
had imagined when i got into it
right right well so so
one of the things that struck me is
towards the end of of the movie aaron
westrick the the officer who um you know
worked with with richard and clifford
these two men who shot each other and
they they re they meet at the end of the
movie i mean was that something that you
planned from the beginning or was that
an organic thing that you kind of
figured out needed to happen halfway
through
yeah i was shooting the first round of
shooting happened as soon as i locked
picture on white tiger which was in
november 2020 we went up and shot the
first round in michigan in northern
michigan
and in talking to aaron westrick the
police officer who was saved by richard
davis's vest and then came to work for
richard davis he started i started
asking him questions about who was the
man that shot you and the more i heard
about that man the more i knew i had to
meet him
and so when we went back in april 2021
um i asked the producers to find some
people and one of them was clifford
washington
and my hope was
that clifford would be an interesting
man a good speaker and of course he was
he was a
very profound speaker and and
had some very deep things to tell us and
um
once i thought of him i thought
structurally would be good for him to
come only in the end of the film as a
kind of out of nowhere surprise
character that would
offer a
antidote or the antithesis of richard's
philosophies
um
that he would negate them in his being
in his presence
and
the idea of them meeting together
happened while i was there shooting i
said my god they should meet one another
and they had not met in 40 years since
the night they shot each other and so i
asked i asked them would you like to
meet and they
you sensed that they needed to do that
they needed you feel it in the scene
that for 40 years they have needed to
have this reconciliation
and
that challenges richard's beliefs you
know now there's two
again like richard is a contradiction
there these two
life forces are contradicting one
another
right right well and so
you you talked earlier about how richard
was not super able
to dive
very deeply into how he felt about
things for whatever reason was it did
you encounter any any hesitancy or fear
from anybody else because this this
movie gets very raw and was there did
anybody else kind of resist
or
kind of express hesitancy at having to
be that vulnerable on camera
i think people revealed themselves as
best they could and as as
as they felt they should and with some
people maybe i felt more
fortunate that they were willing to go
to very difficult places and other
people
perhaps they were less eager to do that
which is i understand it's not an easy
thing to do you're asking from someone
to reveal themselves
right i mean it's you know it can be
kind of a big ask and so it's really
cool that a lot of those people showed
up and gave really really heartfelt and
powerful answers i mean it was really
powerful yeah i i thank you for saying
that i think so too i'm
amazed that some of them did go to those
places yeah
yeah well yeah because i mean there you
know there's not a script you do you
don't really know what these people are
going to say you know so uh that had to
have been really rewarding for you as a
as a filmmaker to to kind of elicit
these
um responses from people
yeah one thing i i learned in making two
short docs and and speaking to werner
herzog about his approach was when you
ask a question and the person answers
don't ask another question so quickly
wait
because in the pause oftentimes
emotionally people reveal themselves but
they may suddenly start talking again
about something you've never thought
about or you didn't ask them they just
want to talk about something
and so a lot of times i just wouldn't
say anything
and suddenly they would just start
talking about what was on their mind
that i didn't even know about and
that learning that strategy or technique
from werner was very helpful it's just
such a great documentary and you do such
a great job threading it all together
but you also don't really come to any
big conclusions you kind of just leave
it to the viewer like you said and i
think that was a really smart
way to do it because there was so much
that was just not even that you couldn't
confirm and so instead of going for
kind of a definitive answer you just
kind of let these people's characters
and their contradictions speak for
themselves and i think that was the more
powerful choice i think you did a really
good job there uh so with
documentaries as an art form and as a
genre i mean what about them do you
appreciate or or admire most
well i i grew up loving
certain documentaries um i loved
herzog's films varda i love varda's docs
and the maiso brothers and wise men
of course in recent times you know
joshua oppenheimer who became a friend
and
you know i just love going into worlds i
don't know about and meeting people i
don't know
and i've tried to do that in a lot of my
own fiction films just diving in the
worlds researching them meeting people
uncovering
the truth about them or their occupation
or the the neighborhood they live in
like in chomp chomp or in 99 homes and
um
so
i'm looking forward to making more
nonfiction films
basically as an opportunity to do that
you know often times i think journalists
have such an enviable job because they
get to
go and meet people and go into worlds
that they never would have access to
otherwise you know and
i think it's just kind of a lucky
a lucky job i have that i get to do that
so is is your process for
kind of sourcing not sourcing people
like gathering information for projects
like between man push cart and chop shop
versus
um
versus second chance does that process
different whether like what were kind of
some of the different requirements of
this project versus those
i mean the meeting of the people and
asking them questions is very similar
you know
if i had carried a camera with me on
chomp shopper man push carter 99 homes
there would have been a documentary
could have easily been made about
all those subjects you know i'm
researching something now for an
original story
because of covet i'm doing a lot of it
by phone but once i can go meet them or
if i recorded the audio of those
conversations it would be a podcast you
know
um of course the difference is with the
fiction film you can
i can take you know three characters
that i've met and turn them into one
person
you know and then you fictionalize
things that they didn't really do or you
invent scenarios but
i've always in my own original work i've
always been drawn to
being inspired from real people in real
situations to create the fictional
version of the story i mean
most everything in 99 homes were things
that i had seen
the events the scams all that i saw
the character you know shannon's
characters based on someone that i met
that mike shannon met that andrew
garfield met
you know um
so
and to me i find it more inspiring than
anything else
is the reality
absolutely when and a lot of fiction is
rooted in some kind of truth you know
it's you're drawing from things that you
you know or the you know things that
actually happened um can you tease
this next project of yours is it like
how kind of far along are you no we're
still writing yeah well awesome yeah so
so
it's my last question for you um
what were
um expand on kind of what the biggest
lessons or themes of second chance are
i think it's about um in some ways it's
about a friendship
it's about um deception it's about
what happens you know what is the
journey from creating something so
in a way so good and so useful to people
and how does that turn into something
that
you know
ends up hurting a lot of people how how
does that happen um
and
what where are we now in terms of truth
power impunity
you know
where do we stand with those
those concepts and ideas in the country
i
i
often thought about it as some
modern version of arthur miller's all my
sons i don't know if you're familiar
with the play but
the father making yeah the father's
making airplanes in the war
the sun realizes that there's faulty
parts in these airplanes and soldiers
are dying
and um
the father's not said anything about it
he didn't do a recall let's say similar
to the story we have in the second
chance
and in that story it's arthur miller so
he goes straight into moral forces right
he was very you know tragic in that way
um in his thinking and um
here you know something similar happened
but there don't seem to be really many
consequences for what happened
and
another company gets created with you
know with products so
i thought found that so
telling of the shift
in where we've gone from from
60 years ago to today
what we believe
what we want to believe so
yeah
absolutely well thank you so much for
your time i i really appreciate it and
uh yeah the movie is great so thank you
thanks thanks for speaking